- Hello everyone.
Good afternoon and thanks
for joining us today.
Welcome to SAS 305:
Using GenAI to profile, scale,
and optimize your multi-tenant
SaaS architecture.
So in this session today,
we're going to look at
how you can fast-track your
SaaS maturity using GenAI
to introduce best-of-breed SaaS attributes
into your SaaS product.
Now, this is a level 300 session.
What that means is
we're not going to be
diving into demos and code,
but we will be doing a lot
of architecture patterns
and showing you real-world use cases
that you can take away and use yourself.
My name is Dave Roberts,
and with my colleague, Damika Sriyananda,
we're both solutions
architects here at AWS,
and we've been working with SaaS
for the last couple of years,
and in the recent year or
two with GenAI as well.
So what are we going to look at today?
Well, first I'm going to look at
what makes best-of-breed SaaS
and how you can use GenAI
to incorporate some of that
into your control plane.
Then Damika is gonna
look at cost analysis,
so things like cost per
tenant, pricing, forecasting.
Then I'm going to look
into customer behavior,
the insights that we can get out of those,
customer personas, packaging,
that sort of thing.
And finally, Damika is gonna round us out
with looking into resource efficiency,
so solving the noisy neighbor problem.
So let's start off and look
at a very common situation.
You've just built your SaaS application.
It's awesome, right?
You're proud of it, you've
put a lot of work into that,
and you've got customers using it.
And to operate that, to manage that,
you've got some business
model going on as well.
Cool.
It's been a couple of years
and hopefully you're getting some revenue
and making some money.
And where you want to go from
here is to grow your SaaS.
So the question is,
what do you need to do to grow your SaaS?
Well, there's three main
areas that we can look at.
One, we can get more customers, right?
More customers equals more revenue,
more revenue equals more profit.
Great stuff.
The other way
is that we can look at getting
more revenue per customer.
So moving customers onto
higher margin packages,
that's gonna give us more profit.
And of course,
the other way is to lower
our operating costs,
so get more resource
efficiency into there.
So these are the things
that we need to do,
but how are we going to do it?
Well, let's look at
best-of-breed SaaS vendors
and what they do.
And when we talk about best-of-breed,
we're talking about those SaaS
vendors out in the market,
you probably know them.
They're standing above
their competitors, right?
You can see them
and they always seem to be one step ahead
and keep pulling forward.
So what's their secret?
Well, it's not really a
secret, it's they use data,
so they know the cost to
serve their customers.
They've got things like cost per tenant,
cost per feature metrics,
and they understand what
their customers are doing.
They've got insights into
their customer behavior.
And of course they focus on
their resource efficiency
because when you first go
live with a SaaS product,
you are focused more on
just getting it going live,
getting products going,
and you're not really
thinking about building
the most efficient architecture.
Now, the problem with that
is that you get some resource wastage,
and as you scale your SaaS,
that resource wastage scales as well.
So best-of-breed knows this
and they focus in on efficiency
because those efficiency gains
are going to scale as well.
And this will give them the edge
because they're able to use this data
to create packages and pricing
that the customers are
going to want, right?
Because if you are choosing a SaaS product
and you've got a couple of competitors
and one of them has exactly what you want
at a price that's fit for you,
well, that's the one
you're going to choose.
And because they've got these insights,
because they have this data,
they're able to forecast the revenue
that's going to be coming in, right?
That's pretty useful as a SaaS business.
And because they're
ultimately more profitable,
they have more profit to
reinvest in themselves.
So you get this nice cycle, right?
They have more profit to reinvest,
they can pull further
ahead, and so on and so on.
So if it's so simple, Dave,
why aren't you doing this right now?
Well, odds are
that you probably have
other things to do, right?
You've gone live with your SaaS,
you are onboarding new customers,
you're adding new features in.
You started off as an architect, right?
Then you turned into DevOps
as you've got the customers going on,
more and more customers.
Now you're just ops,
you're not even doing
architecture anymore.
So nobody's got time
to think about implementing
these sort of features.
And engineering will think
this is a business problem, right?
So until we have some business people,
until your SaaS company scales
that you have these business
functions pushing engineering
to deliver them,
you're going to focus on
what's important for you.
And ultimately, there's
a cost to doing this.
There's a cost in terms
of engineering points,
there's a cost in terms of your time.
So it gets put onto the back burner
until you reach a level of SaaS maturity
and then start incorporating
these features.
Now the problem with this is
that as you operate your SaaS,
you have to make decisions.
And at the moment,
you'd be making decisions
without this data.
So you are already behind on the game
because your competitors
could potentially have these insights.
If your competitors understand
what the customer base wants,
well, you are behind in the game.
And even more dangerous,
you may have unprofitable customers.
It's a common scenario that
I see with SaaS vendors
where they've been going for three years,
they start looking into
their cost per tenant,
they find out they've got these customers
that are unprofitable, they
are hurting their bottom line.
It's not a place that you want to be in.
Now, lots of doom and gloom, right?
But there is a light at
the end of the tunnel
and that's why you're here today, right?
This is what the session is about.
Because GenAI can really
help in this regard.
Because all these things,
these data that we are talking about,
it's all about looking into our data
and finding patterns and finding insights.
And guess what?
This is exactly how LLMs work.
They're great for identifying patterns.
And not only that,
you can use them to get
some value really quickly.
You can get an environment going up,
look into the data you have,
and get some insights in an afternoon.
This is really awesome, right?
You don't have to take months
to build up this environment,
straight away you've got some value.
Or not.
And if you don't, find something else.
And you get this lovely
natural interface, right?
You can use natural language
to query for these insights,
you don't have to be this
intermediate translation
from business question
into technical requirement.
And it also gives us the opportunity
to move beyond just solving
these normal use cases
and looking at what we can do
beyond what's currently now,
so things like real-time
or predictive analysis.
So let's look at an example
SaaS application, right?
You've got your application plan there.
This is where all the good
stuff's going on, right?
The customers are getting their value.
And this is going to scale over time
and you're going to need
to operate and manage that.
So you're going to
introduce a control plane.
And inside the control plane,
we've got a few components.
We've got some data sets,
so our application metrics,
for example, our usage metrics.
We've got a data set which will
handle our tenant metadata,
and we're gonna talk
about tenant metadatas,
information about our
tenants, about our customers,
like which resources
are they allocated to,
what sort of entitlements do
they have, that sort of thing.
And to do all of our heavy lifting,
we have some compute logic, right?
These are our workflows.
So onboarding new customer,
this is where it's going to happen,
change an entitlement, update
our resources, et cetera.
And to interface with these,
we've got this lovely integration layer.
And we can see that we
have a lot of tools,
a lot of resources that
an agent could utilize.
So what would this look
like as an example?
Well, let's say you are inspired.
You come and you do the session,
you're excited about this and you rush,
don't even think about dinner,
you just rush back to your hotel room
and you wanna start playing.
So you get up your nice Kiro environment,
get onto the AWS lab site and see,
hey, we have this CloudWatch MCP server.
All my logs are in CloudWatch,
I'm going to use that.
I'm gonna go ask some question, right?
So all my tenants have
that same usage pattern.
That could be interesting.
So our little LLM friend
is going to go and use their MCP server
and hopefully look in the right place.
And I say hopefully
because your SaaS architecture
is probably pretty complex
and it's hard enough for us to understand,
let alone an agent.
So we can expose the code
base and look into there
and find how you've
done your architecture,
but it doesn't really tell that much
about how you operate as a business.
So we want to be kind to
our future robotic overlords
and give it a bit of context,
tell it a bit about how
our SaaS application works.
Because the better context
you're going to provide,
the better results that
you're going to get.
So now we add that context,
ask that same question,
beep-boop-beep, we get a result.
This is really cool,
we should be able to see some insights
that potentially we didn't have before.
And you're saying, well,
this is great, right?
It didn't take me long
and I'm getting some value out of this.
So where can I go from this?
Well, we can go back to AWS Labs and say,
hey, what other MCP servers do we have?
There's one for Cost Explorer.
Well, that's interesting.
Now I know I have got a
resource to look into the usage
of my customers,
I know how to find the
costs for serving that,
let's find out our cost per tenant.
So we can say,
hey, let's just divide that total cost
by the number of active tenants.
And boom, just like that,
we've got some data,
some insights about cost per tenant.
And I talk constantly with customers
who have been serving their SaaS for years
and they don't have an idea
about the cost per tenant
because it seems so hard.
Well, we've done it in less than an hour.
Easy, right?
And the thing is, it's not perfect,
but now you've got some
figure that you can work with.
And we can look at improving
the accuracy, right?
Because at the moment,
we're just looking at the
number of active tenants
that we have.
Maybe we have some inactive tenants,
that's going to change our
cost per tenant values.
And we have information
on the number of tenants
that we have and their subscriptions,
it's sitting there in our tenant metadata.
We just need a way to expose that
so that our agent can use that.
So we can go and extend
our integration layer,
add some MCP servers there,
and add these into our agent,
and now we can get a more
accurate cost per tenant, right?
And this is awesome, and all we had to do
is expose the control plane a little bit.
And that's really not so
hard because for example,
look at our tenant management.
This is the tenant management service
inside our control plane,
we can see our CRUD operations there,
or to expose these as MCP servers,
we can use something
like AgentCore Gateway.
Makes it really easy, right?
We create this tenant management gateway
and add some targets
through to our API methods
that we want to expose.
And we can repeat this pattern
with our other control plane capabilities.
So resource management,
entitlement management, billing,
anything that could be useful
for us to get insights into.
And once we've done this
little proof of concept
and seeing that we're
getting some insights
that are valuable for us,
either as architects or as a business,
then we can decide that
we want to keep this
and make this a permanent capability
inside our control plane.
So one option is that we could just lift
and shift what we have and deploy that,
now the other is that we
could make it a bit better,
a bit more accurate.
So we want to think about some
sort of architecture pattern
that we can use
because we are going to
be deploying these things
over and over as we
get these new insights.
And it's basically going
to look like this, right?
We're going to have the agent itself,
we're going to have some
deterministic tools,
because if you want to do X divided by Y,
well, create a Lambda, right?
It's easier, cheaper than
getting an agent to do it,
and it's reliable.
We're going to have a
data set or data sets.
This is going to be the results
from anything that we are
deriving in terms of insights.
And some sort of gateway to
expose those for our end users
or other agents.
And for example,
we might have a
deterministic tool that says,
well, every night, I'm gonna go off,
I'm gonna look through our
metrics, aggregate some results,
and put them into our data set.
Now I can expose that to our end users,
nice simple web interface
or maybe some BI tool,
Amazon QuickSee type-thing,
awesome stuff.
Now our end users, our business,
are able to see the insights
that we've garnered.
We can also expose that
to some other agent,
and some other agent can then
come through the gateway,
through some MCP server
that we've exposed,
and they can access that data.
So we can see as we've
created this capability,
we're also able to share those
insights to have a data set
that another capability could utilize
to get even further insights.
And we can do a similar pattern
when we talk about invoking the agent.
So we can provide a
natural language interface
for our business to query,
or we could expose that
to some other agent,
and this is awesome.
And then our agent can use its own tools
or some external tools
to go and do its thing.
So we can see by having this nice pattern,
it lets us be modular
and scale out our insights more and more
so we can get more and more
information about that.
And this is a nice pattern,
you're creating value,
and you're creating more
value and more value.
And to give some examples
of how this would look
in another context,
I'd like to pass back
to my colleague, Damika,
who's going to look into cost analysis.
- Awesome, thanks Dave.
Hey, everybody, welcome
again to the session.
Now that you have a better perspective
about how GenAI capabilities
can be leveraged
in SaaS applications,
let's take a look at some of the examples
starting from the cost analysis.
Now, in general,
cost analysis starts with instrumenting
the application plane
to meet the consumption
matrix of the tenants
so that we can aggregate
them in the control plane
to get the infrastructure
cost per tenant attribution.
And that helped us to
understand the tenants
who are not making so much
of a profit in the business
so that we could do something about that.
Traditionally, this is
where we all got settled
in most of the SaaS applications
in terms of the cost analysis.
Now, GenAI fundamentally
changes the situation
where while it can provide the automation
for the cost analysis,
it can also provide the access
to advanced cost intelligence much easily.
Now, before getting
into the cost analysis,
our story still starts with the
cost per tenant attribution.
Now, Dave will explain how we
can get some of the quick wins
by leveraging GenAI tooling
in the cost per tenant,
but here we will see
how we can make it more permanent design
in the control plane architecture
by using GenAI technologies.
Now in the control plane,
we already got the consumption matrix
and the logs from the tenants.
And now instead of having
hard-coded cost allocation rules
and bulky microservices,
we are gonna introduce an
AI agent for the picture.
And that agent can be
triggered using a prompt,
and that will be kind of
orchestrating the entire workflow
of the cost per tenant attribution
by using the reasoning capabilities
of using the large language model.
Now, during the workflow,
it'll look at the current
usage of the tenants
and then aggregate the matrix out of that
so that it'll know the
list of AWS services
that has contributed to the cost,
and then work with the
Cost Explorer MCP server
to get the unit cost of these matrices
so it can calculate the
cost per tenant accurately.
Now, whenever you are building this
for your SaaS application,
you will feel that,
hey, we need more tools,
more steps in the workflow,
that's totally fine.
The agent will be able to
orchestrate them all for you.
Now, when I know the cost per tenant,
I can easily get the margin
value as well in the same time,
and that's great because
now I can have the cost
and the margin both in the same data set
and then save in the control
plane for the future use.
Now this is gonna be the base
for our cost analysis architecture.
Now, if you look at where the
cost analysis implementation
really get fit into the
control plane architecture,
there are multiple ways of doing that.
One of the ways to think is
to extend the SaaS admin panel
and introducing a cost analysis dashboard
so that we can populate the insights,
the patterns, and the recommendations
we are extracting from the
cost analysis module in there
so that the SaaS admins will
have the access to them.
So with that setup,
we already have
the historical cost
standard margin data set,
came from the previous agentic workflow.
Probably one of the low-hanging
fruits for us to start with
is to look at this data set
and identify the insights and the pattern,
so me as a SaaS provider,
I have a better perspective
about what happened
during the last few months
in terms of cost and the margin.
So for that, we'll have a
cost insight agent here.
Very simple workflow it has.
It'll look at the last
12 months of the cost
and the margin data set,
and then leverage the LLM
and ask for the insights and the patterns.
There's no business logic in here,
just the power of the LLM.
So during this analysis, I can
ask for things like trends,
margin variations, and temporal
and the behavioral patterns.
And this can be entirely customizable
because this is what will go
to the prompt that we send
to the AI agent.
Now, the results of that would
be very much data-driven,
deep insights that will
show me how the margin
and the cost has been wearing
over the last 12 months.
This is awesome
because now I can even understand
some of the opportunities
that I could have done better
to improve my profit margin as well.
Now, another feature that we
can add to the cost analysis
is cost forecasting.
The idea is simple.
You look at the historical data
and then predict the future values, right?
So for that, we are gonna
have a cost prediction agent.
It will look at pretty
much the same data data set
in this example,
like previously the last 12 months data
of the cost and the margin,
and then do the prediction
for the next six months.
Now, as a SaaS provider,
I really want to have this prediction
as accurate as possible
so that I can use them
with a high confidence for my, let's say,
business decision-making
and things like that.
So in order to do that,
I can either go for a library
or a business logic of my own
that will give me the
accurate prediction as well.
Or I can plan to deploy this agent
in the Amazon Bedrock AgentCore runtime,
and then let it know what
kind of prediction algorithm
and the simulation I wanna have.
So the agent will be able to
generate the code using the LLM
and then run that within
the agent code interpreter
so that it will provide
the prediction data set.
So in that case, I'm not even
managing that business logic,
that will be literally
generated by the agent for me.
So likewise, there are many options
with the agentic setup like that.
So when you got the predicted data set,
you're gonna save that for the future use,
and then it'll leverage the LLM,
asking for the insights and the patterns.
Now, during this predictive analysis,
I can ask for things
like forecasting trends,
growth patterns, and the cost
and the margin variations.
Now I have a better perspective
about what's gonna happen
in the next six months
in terms of the SaaS economics as well.
Which is awesome,
now we can actually get
credit for the business
in different forms.
Now, this is great.
I only had the cost per
tenant value sometime ago,
and now with the help of couple of agents,
I now have the historical patterns
and the predictive analysis as well.
Now, before moving ahead,
we want to improve our architecture
because so far we have been discussing
what individual agents
can offer to us, right?
So if you put them all together
into a SaaS architecture,
it's important to look at
how they work each other
as an extendable design.
So here we got the insight
and the prediction agents
that we discussed before.
So one of the changes I would do here
is to introduce the supervisor agent.
So it'll kind of orchestrate
these two agentic workflow
and anything that is
coming up down the line
to extract the response
for the prompts coming from the front end,
in this case, the inside dashboard.
And also as a technical decision,
probably I'll have the cost
per tenant workflow separately
so that I can individually
trigger that when I want
to get the latest cost
and the margin values
into the control plane.
Now with that setup,
it's really interesting
to look at another area
that is AI recommendation.
Can an agent provide
me some recommendations
to optimize the resource utilization
to maximize my margin, for example.
To check out that,
we'll introduce a resource
optimization agent here,
and then I'll provide all the knowledge
about the infrastructure of the system
and the tenant usage of the
infrastructure, that dataset,
as well as a preloaded knowledge
for this agent, so it's
already configured.
And then when that agentic workflow
we got triggered from
the supervisor agent,
so this agent can leverage its own LLM,
now also with the historical
and the forecasted cost
and the margin data set as well,
and asking for the recommendation
for critical infrastructure
changes I need to do
to maximize my profit margin.
Now this is awesome.
Now there's an agent telling me
what are the things I can consider
in terms of the infrastructure changes
to maximize my profit as well.
Now, if your main focus here
is to improve your profit
margin in your business,
which is in every SaaS application,
this is just one side of the story,
optimizing the infrastructure.
The other side would be the tier pricing,
you've got to have the tier
pricing optimized as well.
But if you look at our architecture,
there's one important
dimension that is missing
to have recommendations for tier pricing,
that is the unit cost for the features,
that stands for the average
infrastructure cost required
to host each and every
feature in the architecture.
Why it is important?
Because most, like often,
most of our SaaS applications
are driven by product features
and then we categorize
or group these features
into different tiers, and
we provide a pricing value.
Because of that,
the unit cost of the feature
will have a direct impact
to the tier pricing.
But how can we get it?
It's actually simpler than we think.
We already have the consumption matrix
in the application plane
that have been metered by the tenant ID.
All now what we need to do
is to identify the features
and their workflows along
the architectural components,
and then inject the right feature ID
to the consumption matrix
based on the feature workflow.
That's it.
And then send them onto the control plane.
And in the control plane,
I'm gonna aggregate the
matrix by the feature ID now
and then calculate the
cost, get an average,
and then I will get the
cost per feature data set.
Now I can talk about the
new pricing strategy agent
that we are gonna
introduce into the picture.
So this will give us the recommendations
to optimize the pricing strategy.
For that, I will provide all the knowledge
about the current tiering strategy,
packaging structure, and
the cost into this agent.
And then when it get triggers,
it'll ask for the recommendation.
And now it has a rich set of data sets
to bring in for getting
those recommendations
such as all the cost
of the margin data set
and the new cost per feature as well.
Because of that,
these recommendations
are really comprehensive.
It can come in terms of
the pricing adjustments
where the agent will tell you exactly
what other prices has to be
changed to maximize the profit.
It could be packaging recommendations
where it'll tell you what
should be the list of features
that each and every tier should
have to maximize the margin,
even the new tier opportunities
where we can introduce a new tier,
what is the price of that?
What should be the list of
features that it has as well?
Now I can start optimizing
the pricing strategy as well.
So if you look at our cost
analysis architecture,
the right-hand side,
you've got a nice agentic
workflow that is growing,
we can keep on adding new capabilities.
You've got the supervisor
agent orchestrating them all,
and then extracting the
response for the prompts
coming from the front end,
which is the dashboard in this case.
And like easy feature that
we can actually implement
in here is, of course, the
natural language interface.
So now that SaaS admins are not limited
by what has been shown in the dashboard,
they can even have a conversation
or interaction with the agentic workflow
and get to know more about the insights
and the recommendations as well.
Now, whenever you are building this
for your SaaS application,
I have two recommendations.
Number one, you don't have to
start with everything, right?
Start small but have
extendable architecture
so that you can keep on adding
new features, new agents,
without being worried
about how do you integrate
that to SaaS architecture.
And then work backwards from
your business requirements
so that you know what you
need from the front end,
whether it's a dashboard or
a AI bot or something else
so that you can prioritize
the relevant agentic workflow
at the backend.
I hope this will help you to start off
with your cost analysis workflow
in your SaaS application.
So like cost analysis,
customer insights takes high
priority in SaaS application
where GenAI can help a lot as well.
To talk about that, let
me turn it back to Dave.
- Awesome.
Awesome, thanks Damika.
So customer insights, knowing
what your customers are doing,
it was one of the big
promises of SaaS, right?
You were all on-premise,
you didn't know what your
customers were doing,
well, let's operate and manage
this on our own environment
and we're gonna get insights
into our customer behavior,
we're gonna understand what they're doing.
Awesome, let's do it.
Now, the reality is, I see
this with a lot of customers,
is they're not getting
these insights, right?
And this is a bad place to be
because our customer insights
are really important.
And why are they so important?
Well, basically, they
grow our SaaS, right?
Because if we know what
customers are using,
well, we can spend our engineering points
and make our strengths even stronger.
And something that I've
seen more than once
is where we have a customer
starting to look into their insights
to find out what their
customers are using,
and they find that their
customer base are using features
which aren't really the core product.
And so they decide to pivot
and focus in those
aspects of their product
and they become more successful that way.
And the other side is, it
lets you sell in the way
that customers want to consume, right?
Because if I'm going out there
and I'm looking for SaaS products,
well, I'm gonna choose the
one that has the package
and the pricing that relates
to what I want to use.
And you can use this packaging and pricing
to create these conversion
journeys as well.
So creating a way to get
someone from a basic tier
that gets value from your core product
into a more premium tier
with higher margins.
So we can explore customer behavior
if we go back into our
nice Kiro environment
with some context like we had before,
or we can ask some basic questions, right?
Do we have different customer
personas based on our usage?
And our little LLM friend
is going to do his thing,
beep-boop-beep, and give us some data.
And these insights could be useful, right?
For example, we can see here
that we've got a bunch of
customers here with low usage.
Now that could be
interesting for our business
because those customers
could potentially leave.
We don't want that, right?
We don't want to lose the revenue.
And on the other side,
we've got a bunch of
customers with high usage,
also an interesting thing
from a business perspective
because these customers could be moved
into a higher paying,
more performant tier.
So we'd like to get a few
more insights into this,
but we need to add some more dimensions,
we need to look into feature usage, right?
What features are the customers using?
So we come up with a problem of,
where do we get that feature usage from?
And a common conversation
I've had with SaaS vendors
is that they're going down
and looking into feature usage
but they think that
they have to instrument
their whole application.
And this becomes this roadblock, right?
It's a lots of instrument,
you never get data out,
and when you do, it's incomplete views.
But it doesn't have to be so hard, right?
Because we're building our
applications on the cloud, right?
And you need some sort of way
to access your application,
and this ingress is the perfect
place to take feature usage.
So let's say for example,
if I'm using an API,
well, most of our APIs are
gonna have some opportunities
for access logs,
and most likely each feature
is gonna have their own path.
So we can use a path per feature
as a way to get feature usage dimensions.
Boom, nice and easy, right?
Didn't take any time at all
and now we're getting insights
into our feature usage.
And we can get more
granularity this way as well
because our operations
within that service feature
are probably gonna be different
based on the HTTP method.
So we can use this as another method
of getting some more granularity in there.
And straight away,
we're getting a lot of
insights into feature usage
and didn't really have to do much there.
Now, this doesn't apply to every use case.
Maybe your product
is taking millions of
requests per minute or second
and you don't really want
to turn on those access logs
'cause your bill is going to explode.
So then you need to look at
actually instrumenting your code.
Now this is going to give us
a bit more complexity, right?
Because we actually have
to go into our application,
touch the code.
And if you've got multiple feature teams,
you have to think about
how you're going to standardize
across the teams, right?
'Cause you want some
sort of standardization
because standardization scales, SaaS.
But the benefit to this
is that you're able to get
much richer insights, right?
Because you can instrument
for the dimensions
and the metrics that are
relevant for your business.
So we have to think about that trade off
and balancing that
higher engineering costs
with these deeper insights.
And there's a place for
both approaches, right?
And my general advice is to say,
start off by getting that feature usage
with your ingress logs, right?
Get some data on the table,
stuff that you can work
with straight away.
And then when you need deeper insights
into particular areas,
then start instrumenting your
application code from there.
So now we know how to get feature usage,
let's add that as some context
for our little agent friend.
And now we can ask some questions, right?
What features are my customer's using?
Does its thing, beep-boop-beep,
and gives us some results.
And because it's a natural
language interface,
we can follow this up, right?
We can say, well, based
on that feature usage,
do we see some different personas?
Because customer personas
are really strong.
And when we talk about customer personas,
what we mean is
it's just a group or a
subset of our customers
that we can market to because
they have similar attributes,
they use our product in a similar way.
Because it would be nice
if all of our customers were the same,
but just like the real world,
customers are different
so we need to find out
what sort of different customers we have.
And once we know what
different customers we have,
we can find out their profitability.
Because it would be really interesting
to understand which ones are profitable
or more profitable or unprofitable
because we can use that data
to set our strategy, right?
If we are planning our
customer acquisition
for the next quarter,
we're gonna be spending
this sort of money,
well, what personas are we gonna target?
I'm probably gonna choose for the ones
that are more profitable personally.
But now we have some data to do that.
And we can explore these personas
by building up these
capability sets as well, right?
So I've created this
persona analysis capability,
I'm getting good at it, right?
I've created ones for
usage and cost analysis,
and the agent's just doing half
of this work for me anyway.
And now when I go and query that,
what's that cost per persona?
It can use these other
capabilities recursively, right?
It's going to go and ask
what personas we have,
what sort of feature
usage those personas do,
and then we can use that cost per feature
to get some insights there.
Ask which ones are profitable,
ask do we have any
unprofitable ones, right?
So we're getting this
information that we can use
as data for creating more decisions.
And part of those decisions
and their strategy
is looking at our packaging, right?
And here we're creating
packages for the personas
that we've discovered, right?
Because you can target
your customers better.
And we can plan these
packages to foster an upsell,
to foster a conversion journey.
Another common conversation
I've had with customers
is they create this awesome SaaS product,
it's solving this great use case,
but they only have one service tier
and it's really expensive.
So they can't get new customers on
because their market
base is a small subset
of enterprises that have all that money.
And you need to think about,
well, how can I create
this basic value tier
that gets customers onto my product,
getting value out of that,
integrated into their business workflows
and then pushing them
into more higher value
for the customer and higher margin for you
as the SaaS vendor,
packages in the premium tier.
And once you're planning these packages,
you can forecast the
cost per package as well.
And this is going to be really important.
If we go back to that customer
acquisition example, right?
If I know which personas
I'm going to target
and I have an idea on
what a cost to serve at
and some sort of conversion rate success,
well, I can forecast what
sort of return on investment
I'm going to get by spending
in customer acquisition.
Or maybe you have some RFQs,
if you're a public sector,
RFQs are really common,
well, you need to understand
how low you can go
in terms of your offer and
also make an acceptable margin.
Well, now you've got that data, right?
And you can increase your
revenue with this approach.
And there are other ways
of increasing revenue per customer, right?
One way is by reducing churn.
Because when a customer
leaves, it's a bad thing.
Because not only are they leaving
and they're taking their
revenue stream with them,
but they probably still have the core need
why they came to you in the first place
so they're probably
looking at a competitor.
Now that competitor has
that revenue stream,
they're reinvesting that
to get better than you.
Don't wanna be in that place, right?
So this is why best-of-breed
SaaS vendors have this
as a core mechanism to retain customers.
And the other way by increasing
revenue is upsell, right?
We talked about that,
planning this conversion
journey, upselling.
Well, you need to look
and find the customers
that have potential for upsell.
And again, best-of-breed
SaaS, they know this as well,
and they build this
as core components inside
their business models.
So if you're in an early stage,
you don't have big teams that can do this,
well, how can our little
agent friends help us here?
Well, if we come back to these
capabilities that we created,
let's look at how we can detect churn.
I can go and ask,
set up some scheduled
automated request to say,
every night, go and look for
low usage customers, right?
It's gonna go check our usage metrics.
And if it finds some, it
needs to know what to do.
Now this is then a decision
for you as a business, right?
Because this is ultimately
a business process, right?
What do we do with potential churn risk?
It could be you say,
well, how important is that
customer to my business?
Because if they're really important,
well, we need to get feet
on the ground, right?
We need to be out shaking hands,
finding why they're not happy
and making sure we can retain them.
But that doesn't always scale,
so we end up building in
some sort of automated workflow, right?
Reach out with some templated email.
We've seen these in our inbox, right?
You get this email saying,
oh, please stay, customer.
Here's a 10% discount, whatever.
Very non-personal but it's
got a rate of success, right?
That's why we do it.
But we can improve that, right?
We can invoke our usage
analysis agent and say,
hey, this is the customer
that's at risk of leaving.
Based on their persona and their usage,
what would be a good way
to try and retain them?
So we get a personalized
response for their customer,
and this should yield a
better retention rate.
So this is cool, right?
But we can also improve this as well.
We can turn that customer reach-out
into a customer success function.
And that customer success,
this capability is going to
do the same thing, all right?
It's gonna create that
personalized response,
reach out to the customer,
but now it's tracking these
customer interactions,
it's seeing which ones are
more successful than others.
Basically learning from itself over time.
And we can do a similar approach
by looking at new customers, right?
Because when a new
customer comes on board,
we wanna make sure that they
get a short time to value,
they want to get them using your product,
getting that value locked in.
So we can do the same thing,
that same approach and just say,
well, if they have low usage
and they're a brand new customer,
we'll send them something that's
maybe more of a quick start
than trying to retain them, right?
And we can use these
same tools for upselling,
except now instead of looking
for low usage customers,
we're looking for high usage customers,
or maybe customers that
use specific feature sets.
And again, once we see an opportunity,
we follow that same approach,
reach out to our customer
success capability
and create this personalized approach,
except now we are looking
to upgrade the customer
instead of retaining them.
And these capabilities,
these aren't brand new things, right?
I didn't invent customer success.
If you've been in the
SaaS field for a while,
you know that customer success
is a standard business
unit, standard capability.
And things like usage analysis,
that's been done by product owners
since product owners started.
But the difference is that
now you're able to
implement these with agents
without having to build up head count,
without having to build up
physical teams to do this.
And this is really, really
awesome because that means
that you can start getting
these best-of-breed,
these mature SaaS attributes
straight from day one.
And we can see that
not only is GenAI fundamentally changing
how we build our SaaS products,
it's also fundamentally changing
how we operate them as well.
And to give another example of this,
I'd like to pass back to Damika,
who's going to look at resource management
and resource efficiency.
- Thanks Dave.
So resource management in SaaS
is always a balancing act.
You provision too little,
it'll impact the performance.
If you end up provision
too much of infrastructure,
it'll kill be profit margins, right?
So that's why it's critical
but also very challenging
control plane service to have.
So this is where GenAI can
help a lot to automate,
to improve the operational efficiency,
and also the agility
of the overall module.
Resource management always starts
with the resource monitoring.
If you look at how we used to do that
in traditional SaaS applications,
we already had the consumption matrix
and the access logs of the
tenants in the control plane.
And then we define the
service level objectives
for the solution, SLOs.
This stands for the
infrastructure level thresholds
that the tenants are allowed
to use at the maximum level.
And then we had the
monitoring microservice
constantly looking at the tenant usage
and checking if there
is any SLO violations.
If so, there is a notification
to the DevOps team.
So the DevOps team comes in,
identify the issue, identify the fix,
and then verify once the fix is done,
the whole bunch of manual work down there.
So if you really wanna
bring some acceleration
and quick wins using GenAI,
you can always lean into a
preloaded AI agent like Kiro CLI,
provide the context,
let it know how the solution works,
and brainstorm about the notification
that you may have received
or about anything directly
about the attendance as well,
it will provide some guidance.
But if you really want
to make this automated
as a part of the SaaS architecture,
one of the first things that you wanna do
is to understand how the
SaaS resource monitoring
and the management workflow
would work, like is,
and so that, how can you automate that?
So everything starts with
the resource monitoring.
Why?
Because then we can
understand the anomalies,
which are the suspicious tenant activities
that ideally, they are still
violations, but with GenAI,
you will see that there is
a broader scope than that.
So once we know the anomalies,
then we need to figure out
whether they are actually,
if they are leading
into anything critical,
any critical conditions,
anything concerning such as noise enablers
or resource misuses or API
spikes and things like that.
So for that, with GenAI,
we can leverage pattern recognition.
So once we know the
potential critical condition,
then we can focus GenAI
components looking at them
and identify the corrective actions,
which are the infrastructure level changes
that we need to do to
mitigate those conditions.
And then we can go and
fix them, monitor them,
and then verify if the
condition has been resolved.
Now when you want to automate this
for your SaaS application,
certainly there will be
more steps coming up,
but I would consider
this as the bare minimal
that you need to automate anyway.
So let's see how this
flow can be implemented
using GenAI technologies.
Now for the anomalies,
we are gonna implement an
anomaly detection agent
that can be triggered using
a prompt simple workflow.
It'll take the current usage
of the tenants, and then SLOs,
and leverage to the LLM
ask for any anomalies.
So in the prompt you can ask
to crosscheck the current
usage with the SLOs
and also any additional
considerations as well,
such as consider on the business impact,
consider on the tier configuration
of this particular tenant
and the impact to the
other tenants of the tier,
and things like that.
So based on your SaaS application,
you can keep on adding more
and more considerations.
So what happens is now the agent
is having better and bigger
scope to identify the anomalies
without missing out anything else.
So once we know the anomalies,
at this stage we are gonna log them
into the resource analysis data store
and then move on to the next step.
If you look at these anomalies,
they are filled with data points
that justifies why the agent
thought this would be anomaly,
such as the statistical analysis
of the threshold violations,
and also the LLM analysis
will also provide some level of details.
So once we know these anomalies,
next is to identify
whether these are leading
into anything critical,
any critical conditions.
So for that,
we are gonna add a pattern
recognition agent in here.
Now for the pattern recognition agent,
we will provide the knowledge
to the agent upfront
about the potential critical condition
that could have happened
in the SaaS architecture.
For example, how do you
define a noise enabler?
And how do you identify a resource misuse
and security issues and things like that?
So that knowledge is already
there with the agent.
So with that, when it gets
executed with the workflow,
first take the anomaly that was identified
and then get the tenant ID or tenant,
and then get all the current
and the historical usage data
from the control plane.
And then leverage to the LLM,
and then ask for potential
critical conditions.
Now through the prompt,
we can specifically mention
to conduct the usage temporal
and the behavioral pattern recognition
of this given anomaly
against the historical
or the usage data set,
so the agent will know how
many times this anomaly
or something similar to this
anomaly has been repeated
in the past
and what is the criticality
and the importance of that
so that it can map the anomaly
into a critical condition that's given.
So once we identify any
potential patterns like that,
we will log them in here,
in the resource analysis
data store and move forward.
And these potential patterns
will clearly mention
what is the condition that is concerning.
For example, in this case,
Tenant 004 has been identified
as a potential noisy neighbor.
Why?
That anomaly has been
repeated about 100-plus times
during last few days,
70% of which has been
during the last two hours.
And also the agent has
predicted that 80% of that
will likely to happen in the
next three hours as well.
It relates to heavy CPU and resource usage
during the off-peak time,
certainly someone has to
look into this immediately.
However, if you look at our architecture,
we are not yet ready to process
those critical conditions,
we just have a couple of agents only,
so it needs some improvement.
First improvement, we are
gonna have a supervisor agent
for the orchestration,
and then we will introduce
a condition specific agentic layer
where there will be a dedicated agent
per critical condition.
One for noise neighbors, one
for handling resource misuses,
maybe one for security as well
who will be handling cases like
unauthorized cross-tenant
data access and so on.
So the advantage is that
now I can provide focused knowledge,
the tools, and the capabilities agent-wise
based on their focus area,
based on the condition
that they're focusing on
so that their decision-making capabilities
will be much more advanced and accurate.
So maybe the final enhancement
to the architecture
at this stage is
if you look at the resource
analysis data store,
we have been keep on
adding all the anomalies,
the patterns, critical conditions,
and down the line you will see
we'll add all the corrective actions
and the actual fixes that we are doing
into the same data store.
So over time,
this data source is gonna be
the single source of truth
that represent the entire SaaS monitoring
and the management module
of the SaaS application.
It's a huge amount of knowledge.
So what we can do is
I'm gonna connote this
into a vector store and build
a knowledge base out of that,
and then inject that knowledge
to each and every specialist
agent that I have.
So now they are more capable,
the addition making would
be much more accurate
with the historical knowledge as well.
Now with this,
if you move on to the architecture
and then see if you have a noisy neighbor,
potential noisy neighbor to handle,
like in our previous example,
the supervisor agent just need to trigger
the noisy neighbor agent
which is already configured
with the knowledge and the tools
and it'll refer to the potential pattern
and then ask for two things from the LLM,
can you confirm whether this
is actually a noisy neighbor?
So the agent will use
the existing knowledge
to decide whether that is
a noisy neighbor or not.
If yes, what are the corrective
actions we need to do
to mitigate the situation?
So if you look at the output,
it will clearly mention the confirmation
and also the corrective
actions that we need to do
at the infrastructure level.
So this format will be same
for all the critical conditions
that you're gonna have in our solution.
Now this is great, right?
This is great.
But the big question is
who's gonna verify this?
Who's gonna do this?
Traditionally, we had
our DevOps team coming in
and doing these infrastructural changes,
but now we have an agentic layer
doing most of the stuff for us.
So where we have to lean in in this case.
So there are many options.
So my recommendation is
when you have these kind
of corrective actions
or critical conditions found
in your SaaS application,
prompt that to a natural
language interface
and have a human in the loop.
Ideally an expert in the house
on DevOps who can come in
and review these critical conditions
at the corrective actions.
And then maybe ask questions
from the agentic layer
about these options, get to know them more
and verify what needs to
be executed out of these,
if not all.
And then use the existing
DevOps and the GenAI tools
to do the fixes
and let the supervisor agent know about it
so that it can self-generate a prompt
that will trigger the existing pipeline,
but this time only for
this particular tenant
and only to verify the fixes
for the critical condition.
That's it.
So that way we are kind of
reusing the same workflow,
same pipeline without having any,
without needing to have any
additional instrumentation
for monitor and verify.
What we can do is we can even
have a verification window
during which we will run
this prompt few times
just to absolutely make
sure that the fix worked.
All right.
So again, when you
wanna kind of adopt this
to a new SaaS application,
I highly recommend to have
the human in the loop option
that will improve the confidence
of the infrastructure level
changes that you are doing
in your production system.
And also it'll help you to
understand overall accuracy
of the output of the agentic layer
so any improvements can be identified.
So you can keep on
modernizing the agentic layer
until you have a better
confidence about the output
so that you can even plan to pass
or hand off some of the responsibilities
to the agentic layer as well.
Hope this will help you
to entirely automate your SaaS monitoring
and the management layer by
using GenAI technologies.
All right, so we talked
a lot about GenAI today
and how we can bring
the GenAI capabilities
into the SaaS control plane.
We took a lot of examples
in explaining that as well.
So in summary as key takeaways,
if you are early into
the process, start small.
There are enough preloaded AI agents
and MCP service out there
that you can use to put together,
get something up and running,
that show some results real
quick in your control plane.
So always lead your teams
to that to start with.
If you are there already,
identify a few areas
that you can modernize
in your control plane and bring
the agentic capabilities in.
I highly recommend
you have a closer look at
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore service
and its features, it has
a lot to offer to you.
Feel free to bring the right tools
and bring the right
capabilities to the agent
so that their decision making
capabilities will be higher.
And also always start with the data.
If you don't see the right data
set that an agent requires,
start from instrumenting
the application plane
and bring the data set
first into the control plane
so that you can then talk
about the agentic workflow.
So finally take the leadership
to kind of provide the
guidance required to your team
and the organization to
bring the GenAI capabilities
into this control plane.
Now that you know,
it's not only the automation
and the operational efficiency,
but it can also help things
like maximizing the profit margin
of the SaaS application as well.
Now we went through these
three use cases much deeply
in terms of the design and implementation
just to showcase you what is
possible and how it is done.
So I highly recommend that
you plan to implement them
in your SAS application,
and in general my call to
action for you all would be,
identify the remaining
control plane services as well
that you wanna modernize and
feel free to bring the agents
and the GenAI capabilities into
the implementation as well.
All right everybody,
so this is the kind of content
that we want to share with you all.
I hope this is what you expected
from the session as well,
and I believe now you
have a better perspective,
better confidence about bringing GenAI
and the agentic capabilities
into the control plane.
Just a quick couple of
things before wrapping up.
These are some of the SaaS sessions
that our team is hosting
during next few days
in the re:Invent as well.
So if you're interested,
please take a note of it.
There are some workshops
and the builder sessions
that will be very hands-on as well.
And finally, there should be a survey link
for this particular
session in your mobile lab.
So please let us know your
feedback, super important.
We will be looking at
them with high interest
to learn from you
and also to shape up our future
re:Invent sessions as well.
All right, everybody,
a huge thank you to all of you
for being here in this evening.
Thanks Dave for co-presenting
with me as well.
I wish you all have a
awesome remaining part
of the re:Invent, everybody.
Have a wonderful evening.
(audience applauds)